ja also mit mit nachdenklichem blick
sehe ich die bilder der
flüchtlingsströme oder die bestellung
der geflüchtete die menschen die in
unser land kommen und ich sehe mit
großer freude
die hilfsbereitschaft aber ich sehe doch
extrem sorgenvoll dass wir auch auf dem
weg in ein neues 2015 sind was ich damit
meine ist es droht wieder wenn er nicht
sogar schon da ist der verlust der
kontrolle darüber wer eigentlich in
unserem land ist und das finde ich schon
außergewöhnlich quälend das aus den
ereignissen von 2015 und den jahren
danach wo wir uns stunden und tage und
monate lang darüber belehren lassen
mussten dass man in zukunft besser
vorbereitet ist auf die grossen
migrationsbewegungen
offensichtlich nichts gelernt hat es
gibt keine registrierung an den grenzen
es gibt keinen expliziten schutz für
frauen und kinder es ist quasi freie
bahn für schleuser und menschenhändler
und alles funktioniert wieder nachdem
wird schon gut gehen prinzip hoffnung
und ich glaube dass es nicht gut gehen
wird weil wenn wir uns die zahlen
anschauen dann sehen wir am heutigen tag
das ungefähr 175 tausend menschen
erfasst sind von den zeitlich erfasst
die nach deutschland gekommen sind und 6
prozent davon sind keine ukraine
das steht jetzt schon fest 6 prozent von
175.000 sind rund 10.000 menschen sind
also jetzt bereits illegal ins land
gebunden und mehr noch als das das ist
gefährlich auf der einen seite wir
wissen viele von ihnen sind aus
nordafrika da gehen alle alarmlampen an
und wenn man dann nachrichten zur
kenntnis nehmen muss wie die aus
düsseldorf wo zwei männer aus tunesien
und nigeria die auch einen ukrainischen
pass hatten eine frau sexuell bedrängt
missbraucht haben dann müssen die
alarmlampen ja so leicht so hell
leuchten wie nur möglich es ist aber
auch noch teuer denn wenn 10.000
menschen illegal im land sind und die
allgemeine formel gilt dass man für
einen flüchtling im land ungefähr 1000
euro pro monat für unterkunft und essen
rechnet dann ist es ja schon mal 10.000
mal 1000 euro im monat das sind zehn
millionen euro so gefährlich und teuer
und deshalb kann es nur eines geben
bitte bitte bitte grenzkontrollen so
schnell wie möglich klare registrierung
wenn sich rausstellt jemand ist kein
ukraine bitte ab nach hause das ist auch
teil von humanismus dass man sich um die
um die man sich kümmern muss wirklich
kümmern kann dadurch dass man die um die
man sich nicht kümmern muss auch wieder
wegschickt andernfalls mache ich mir die
sorge und das ist mein zentraler gedanke
von heute dass deutschland in die
geschichte eingeht als das land das
masken sünder und falschparker schärfer
bestraft und härter verfolgt als
illegale einwanderer und das wird uns
große probleme ja ich kann sagen einige
genau dieser sorgen haben wir heute im
bundestag zur sprache gebracht als die
innenministerin nancy faeser heute bei
der regierungsbefragung im bundestag war
und sie hat uns diese sorgen
größtenteils nicht genommen ich will
eine einschränkung machen ich glaube der
vergleich zu 2005 10 hat natürlich ein
paar schwierigkeiten das gute ist was
ich zu 2015 unterscheidet es die
europäische einigkeit und ich glaube
auch die situation der flüchtlinge der
ukraine der europäer ist noch mal eine
andere als wir sie 2015 hatten aber
eines ist richtig das ist sozusagen nur
die kleine vorbemerkung richtig ist dass
wir im moment nicht hinreichend gut
kontrollieren die identitäten nicht
feststellen dass die innenministerin das
nicht mal als problem an erkennt ich
hätte ja verständnis dafür wenn man
jetzt sagen würde dieses und jenes ist
schwer aber wir erleben im moment und
das ist eine katastrophe hier in berlin
am hauptbahnhof wie wir gerade viele
frauen aus der ukraine hier billigend in
die hände schreiben von den falschen
leuten wie wir eine situation erleben
wie wir eben nicht den die möglichkeiten
die wir haben fokussieren auf die die im
vordergrund sein sollten und wir leben
es ist keine planung da es gibt kein
krisenstab kein flüchtlings koordinator
nichts und die innenministerin sieht das
nicht mehr als problem das halte ich für
den falschen aber ist also ich mit wie
ich sehe natürlich die unterschiede
andere vorzeichen
es ist auch ein anderer kultureller raum
aus dem die flüchtlinge kommen ich bin
aber bewusst einmal nicht auf diesen
punkt eingegangen weil es sind halt
menschen in afrika dagegen alle
alarmlampen an
naja du gut also ich meine habe die
domplatte auch erlebt und alles und wenn
nicht dann wenn ich jetzt eigentlich
alle dinge
aber die entschuldigung nicht die noch
von der masse nicht
jetzt müssen das doch noch mal sortieren
aus nordafrika kommen
junge alleinreisende männer den angriff
kannte ich vorher auch nicht und das ist
eine andere klientel da werden künftige
nobelpreisträger genauso dabei sein wie
menschen die gegen das in dem fall war
es jetzt irak und nigeria tunesien und
nigeria so und wir lassen die die der
unterschied ist natürlich an andere
kultur raum ein anderes verständnis von
zusammenleben und eine andere biografie
aber die analogie ist das aufgezählt
keine kontrolle keine registrierung es
ist uns eigentlich egal wer kommt es
wird schon gut gehen und es wird nicht
gut gehen es wird auch sozusagen unter
in der gruppe der geflüchteten zu
schwierigkeiten kommen das ist doch also
ich mir fällt fast nichts anderes ein
wie das wort schande dass man in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft eine 18 jährige
frau aus der ukraine
sozusagen ins nebenzimmer steckt zu zwei
männern aus einem anderen kulturkreis
das kann doch nicht wirklich überzeugen
durch deutsche und das gibt es natürlich
auch mal fragen was ist passiert der
offensichtliche punkt jetzt wie viele
aus nordafrika haben die jetzt ich über
spitze das als eine art trittbrettfahrer
diese situation ein das ist ja sogar so
wiesen augsfeld müssen wir halt wenn man
eintaucht in die ist es doch klar also
wir machen mal nur das planspiel wenn
ich jetzt schleuser wäre und mein geld
damit verdienen würde menschen aus
afrika nach deutschland zu bringen oder
in die eu zu bringen macht es noch
weiter dann hätte ich doch jetzt den
jackpot die route ist doch klar sie geht
über die türkei und russland und die
ukraine dann braucht man zwei pässe der
treppenwitz schlechthin war doch jetzt
habe ich gelesen dass die beiden die die
beiden aus düsseldorf hatten zwei pässe
und wie kommen die ins land die zeigen
bei der ausreise natürlich nicht ihren
ukrainischen pass dann müssten sie
nämlich kämpfen sie zeigen bei der
ausreise ihren nigerianischen passt und
bei der einreise in deutschland ihren
ukrainischen und wenn wir uns so
reinlegen lassen von leuten die unsere
sozialsysteme ausnutzen wollen dann sind
wir doch in einer vergleichbaren
situation zu 2005 das möchte hier auch
mächtig an der akzeptanz der ukraine
bringen
ich glaub an dich denken weil ich gut
wird das starr quasi
sein wollen und ich möchte noch eine
frage an die runde stellte gebe ich dir
ein wenig was ja schon ziemlich gerade
angesprochen hat sind die doppelpässe
das heißt es menschen haben einen
klinischen pass und einem anderen land
das ist sie eigentlich zwei
staatsangehörigkeiten deswegen die frage
an sie ein wenig ich bin in dem glauben
aufgewachsen bei mir zu hause dass alle
menschen gleich sind und jetzt stellt
sich aber die hunde auch in der
diskussion die frage ist es doch nicht
so muss man ein richtiger flüchtling
sein ich möchte das beispiel nicht
verharmlosen was da gerade aus
düsseldorf angesprochen hast aber es
gibt ja auch menschen die beide pässe
haben dürfen die dann nicht ausreisen
wie stehen sie dazu als diplomat
also was für uns zählt ist diese warme
empfang denn meine landsleute hier nach
einer langen langen reise und nach nach
dem was sie erlebt haben hier erfahren
am hauptbahnhof an vielen anderen
bahnhöfen hier in deutschland und das
ist das was für uns in erster linie
zählt nämlich dass die menschen hier
wirklich mit offenen armen
ukraine der ukraine sind vor allem
frauen und kinder die fliehen konnten
dass sie hier so warmherzig aufgenommen
werden und dass das was zählt natürlich
gibt es dann viele probleme und das was
wir jetzt erleben in unserem konsulat in
berlin da kommen hunderte menschen jeden
tag die gar keine reisedokumente
mitnehmen weil sie mussten so schnell
fliehen aus der ukraine das egal dass
sie haben vielleicht eine kopie ihres
passes und das ist dann die sorgen die
wir jetzt haben hauptsache ist dass das
man dass diese dass diese solidarität
nicht nachlässt dann klar also 21 tage
krieg und wir sehen viele möglichkeiten
oder viele probleme jetzt bei der
koordination ich werde das thema auch
bei der innenministerin selbst
ansprechen und auch hier in der
senatsverwaltung damit man das besser
koordiniert weil wir wollen nicht dass
diese menschlich ist ihnen die hände von
menschenhändlern
geraten das wäre das schlimmste was
ihnen noch zustoßen sollte danach nach
diesem groll die sie erlebt haben ich
will noch mal weil das wirklich das so
schön konkret mit den beiden passen es
ist ja nichts dagegen einzuwenden dass
austauschstudenten zwei pässe haben dass
menschen die in zwei länder es könnte
aber genauso gut sein dass es ein
nigerianer und ein tunesier sind die
sich für fünf euro irgendwo einen
ukrainischen pass gekauft haben und ich
möchte dass wir bei der einreise
sicherstellen ob es die eine gruppe oder
die andere gruppe ist und der der einzig
gekauft hat für fünf euro kommt halt
nicht rein ganz einfach so würde ich es
in meinem eigenen haus aufmachen und
dass dieser staat nicht in der lage ist
das zu unterscheiden und jetzt er schon
darüber nachdenkt wie wir heute hören ob
man nicht mit vokabeln arbeiten kann
also zum beispiel ob man gar nicht mehr
flüchtlinge sagt sondern vertriebener
und dann greifen bei vertriebenen
möglicherweise andere regeln also da
darf man nicht kontrollieren und so was
das allein sowas gedacht wird um das
eigene versagen wieder zu über gleis
dann erinnert mich an alles was wir bei
corona erlebt haben und es ist scheinbar
eine systemische frage der deutschen
politik der letzten zwei bis fünf jahre
und jetzt verlangt ja niemand dass man
irgendwie nur weil jemand aus nordafrika
kommt ein anderes recht anwendet die
austauschstudentin die in kiew unterwegs
sind und jeder aus kiew fliehen die
bekommen hier natürlich den status nach
dieser richtlinie der eu aber jetzt
brauchen wir doch keiner erzählen dass
jetzt hier lauter nordafrikanische
austauschstudenten aus der ukraine
fliegender und des reisenden muss man an
dieser stelle einfach nicht pauschal
diskriminiere aber das recht anwenden
weil diese schlimmen fälle des
asylmissbrauchs wenn die dann die presse
abonnieren die gesamte ist es so
schwindet die gesamt akzeptanz weil dann
sagen die leute die poliere regionale
trennen nicht zwischen denen die
wirklich den schutz brauchen jetzt vor
putins raketen fliegen und denen die
trittbrettfahrer auf diesem weg lassen
sie uns doch alle einmal zu peróns heime
nach kiew schreiten der ja nicht das
erste mal als kriegsreporter ist
unterwegs ist dann schon so vielen
ländern war mit gerne mal seine
einschätzung zu der thematik hören auch
vielleicht zu klaus und meinem kleinen
disput eben
ehrlich gesagt halte ich mich da gerne
raus was in deutschland passiert das
sehe ich seit sehr vielen wochen nicht
weil ich die ganze zeit aus der ukraine
berichte und nimmt es mir nicht übel
aber ich habe natürlich da vor allem die
perspektive derjenigen die hier
vertrieben werden habe da einfach großes
mitgefühl wenn man vor
völlig zerstörten häusern steht wenn man
erlebt wie hier jede nacht jeden morgen
diese reden gehen dann macht man keinen
unterschied erstmal zwischen ist das
jetzt ein austausch student oder ist das
ein ukrainer das sind menschen die
einfach fliehen nichtsdestotrotz kann
ich die kritik natürlich verstehen dass
man das grundsätzlich prüfen sollte nur
ich glaube
dass das so zu sagen wenn es passiert
also wenn sozusagen der strom da ist
jetzt dass es dann immer zu spät ist was
mich schon wundert ist dass wir nach
2015 offenbar keine verbesserung dieses
systems gebaut haben ja also was ist mit
der digitalisierung warum gibt es
sozusagen beim versuch auch ausweise zu
kontrollieren keine bessere methode was
ist mit den grenzkontrollen
da sehe ich keine veränderung oder
verbesserung und das deutet doch darauf
hin dass die politiker gedacht haben
jahr 2015 das wird sich schon nicht mehr
wiederholen ja und jetzt sehen wir wie
schnell sich etwas wiederholen kann und
es gibt ja politiker die sagen dass
dieser flüchtlingsstrom der schlimmste
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg oder der
größte seit dem zweiten weltkrieg werden
könnte und wieder noch vor sehr sehr
viel größeren problemen stehen werden
den nächsten wochen und monaten wenn
putin nicht aufhört hier zu bomben